Eu queria agradecer
o convite que o TEDx me fez
Eu mandei um email a perguntar:
"Então que querem que eu aí vá dizer?"
E a resposta foi:
"Podes falar sobre tudo o que
te apetecer que tenha a ver com artistas".
e eu fiquei um pouco baralhado e disse:
"Mas... aquilo não é
uma universidade, não são estudantes?
"É sobre isso que eles querem
ouvir falar?
"Não sei se vou conseguir"
Então, deparei-me com uma dificuldade.
"Como é que eu em 15 minutos
ponho 25 anos daquilo que fiz?"
Vocês não me conhecem,
pelo menos a maior parte não conhece.
Há aqui alguém que me conheça? Não.
Há aqui duas pessoas que me conhecem.
Muito bem. Já há quatro.
Não é que eu queira, mas certamente
muitas das coisas que fiz vocês conhecem.
Qual foi a maior peça de teatro
que vocês viram nos últimos tempos?
Pode até ter sido
há muito tempo, mas que vos marcou.
Ninguém vai ao teatro.
Isso é que é mau.
Qual foi o grande espetáculo
que vocês viram que não seja festivais,
que não seja música?
Fostes ver o Cats,
fostes ver a Conversa da Treta.
Estas duas coisas são talvez
duas das coisas mais importantes
que aconteceram nestes últimos anos.
A Conversa da Treta foi a revolução
daquilo que é o teatro comercial,
que é "isto tem público,
então não presta".
Foi a primeira coisa
que eu ouvi, dita por um jornalista.
Então espera aí:
a arte que tem público não presta,
a arte que tem pouco público
é subsidiada, altamente interessante.
E os meus paradigmas foram
crescendo, crescendo, crescendo
e eu fui-me
esquecendo disto e fui fazendo.
E o que é que eu fui fazendo?
Juntei dois génios — eles já o eram —
não fui eu que fiz deles os génios.
Juntei o José Pedro Gomes
e o António Feio
porque eu estava a fazer os STOMP,
um dos grupos mais conhecidos
e que há mais de 12 anos faço em Portugal,
e encontrei estes dois senhores
que me contaram uma história.
O teatro em Portugal
não vai a lado nenhum,
não o conseguimos promover,
ninguém nos liga nenhuma.
Eu saí do grande auditório
do Centro Cultural de Belém
e fui para o pequeno auditório
onde eles estavam a fazer um espetáculo.
Onde é que nós nos encontrávamos?
No bar.
E no bar eu dizia: "Mas não é
possível! Nós temos 1200 pessoas"
"— o grande auditório estava cheio —
"e vocês têm 500 no pequeno auditório
que também está cheio.
"Portanto, não é verdade quando
dizemos que o teatro não tem público."
Algum teatro não tem público,
nomeadamente aquele que é subsidiado.
Tem sempre muito pouco público.
E o que é que nós fazemos?
Arrancámos. Eu junto o Zé Pedro, o António
e começo a promover teatro
e a fazer digressões pelo país inteiro
— estamos a falar de qualquer coisa
como há 20 anos atrás —
e começamos a encher salas.
Portanto, passámos a fazer,
pura e simplesmente, teatro comercial.
Assumidamente, teatro para o público.
E, desde aí, nunca mais parámos.
Ora com o Zé Pedro e com o António,
depois com uma série de outros artistas
como o Miguel Guilherme,
o Bruno Nogueira mais recentemente,
a Maria Rueff, a Ana Bola,
as salas têm estado
permanentemente cheias.
O que é que nós fizemos?
Encarámos o teatro de outra maneira.
E aí começam os "ses":
"E se fizéssemos,
e se fizéssemos, e se fizéssemos".
E foi isso que nós fizemos.
Ou seja, não ficámos parados,
não ficámos sentados,
experimentámos, arrancámos,
testámos e tivemos o público.
Isso é o que eu faço
no meu dia-a-dia e quando estou na UAU.
Todos os nossos projetos
têm sempre, atrás de qualquer coisa,
"e se... as pessoas não vão?",
"e se... o público não gosta?".
Ora, como nós vivemos
do público e dos bilhetes,
estes "e ses" são
permanentemente problemas
que temos de transformer
em coisas alegres.
São sempre aventuras.
Então o que é que nós fizemos?
Procurámos qualidade,
procurámos projetos interessantes
e fomos buscar o que de melhor
se fazia no mundo do bailado.
Fomos buscar o Maurice Béjart.
Trouxemos a Portugal
e os críticos diziam:
"Isto é muito comercial,
não vai correr bem.".
Depois na altura, tivemos um jornalista
que escreveu no Centro Cultural de Belém:
"Mais um fiasco a caminho de Portugal",
uma coisa que era muito comercial
porque, na altura, o Maurice Béjart
tinha feito uma coreografia
dos Queen e do Mozart
com roupa Versace.
E a coisa correu muito bem.
Aliás, com esse jornalista passei eu
uma tarde no Centro Cultural de Belém,
a ler a crítica que ele conseguiu fazer
um dia antes de o espetáculo
ter acontecido,
o que é notável mas é verdadeiro.
E então estava uma fila inteira
no Centro Cultural de Belém,
jornal aberto, eu e ele, e eu a dizer:
"Eh pá, tu deves ter sido o único tipo
que conheço no mundo
"que conseguiu fazer uma crítica
a um espetáculo que ainda não aconteceu.
"Porque tu ainda não conseguiste
ver mas já o conseguiste criticar".
Portanto, eu estou sempre no "e se...",
falta-me sempre qualquer coisa,
tenho sempre
um problema qualquer.
E vamos, e vamos, e vamos,
e vamos ultrapassando.
Um dia viajei até à Argentina,
onde vi um dos espetáculos
mais notáveis da minha vida.
Não sei se alguns de vocês viram,
não esteve no Porto, foi de La Guardia
e depois, mais tarde,
um outro chamado Força Bruta
e ainda um musical dos Xutos e Pontapés.
Não sei se alguém teve oportunidade de,
em Lisboa, assistir a estes espetáculos.
Está aqui alguém que
tenha visto algum destes?
Não.
Então que é que aconteceu?
Nós estávamos na Argentina
e depois de vermos um espetáculo notável,
deparamo-nos também com um problema:
não há sala em Portugal
para fazer esse espetáculo.
Não cabe!
"Então mas não cabe?
Temos que conseguir fazer."
Então viemos no avião
e eu e o diretor técnico da UAU:
"E se construíssemos um teatro?
Somos malucos, não faz sentido nenhum,
nós não vamos conseguir fazer um teatro."
Mas, no avião, a viagem foi longa, nós
fomos fazendo os esquiços todos do teatro
e, uma semana depois
de estarmos em Lisboa,
já estávamos com engenheiros
e empresas a construir um teatro.
Sozinhos não conseguíamos,
foi preciso encontrar um patrocinador
e nasce, em Lisboa, a Toyota Box,
um espaço que esteve
três anos em Alcântara
e assim conseguimos
trazer os espetáculos da Argentina,
conseguimos fazê-los e a coisa correu
tão bem que conseguimos fazer em Lisboa,
Madrid e Barcelona.
Um megassucesso
sempre a construir os teatros.
"E se"... nós não
tivéssemos ido à Argentina,
"e se"... nós não tivéssemos conseguido
fazer o teatro para fazer o espetáculo.
A vida da UAU
e aquilo que nós temos feito na UAU
passa um bocadinho por isto, passa
por encontrar coisas em que acreditamos
a que não viramos as costas, são desafios.
São projetos em que nós acreditamos
e que lutamos para fazê-los.
Não muito contente com tudo isto
— e como o Álvaro disse no início —
o meu pai trabalhava na TAP quando tudo
isto começou e eu tinha a sorte de viajar.
Então o que é que eu tinha?
Eu tinha sempre
hipóteses de estar no estrangeiro,
— estamos a falar de há 30 anos atrás —
e de começar a questionar:
"Porque é que isto
não se faz em Portugal?"
"Porque é que não
conseguimos fazer isto?"
"Porque é que os grandes musicais
não vêm cá?"
"Porque é que só se fala de música?"
Porque nunca
ninguém os tinha convidado para vir.
E eis que nós,
a partir do nosso escritório,
os começamos a convidar para vir.
E vem quem?
Os Chicago, um desastre brutal.
Perdemos um milhão
de euros em três semanas.
Nem eu sabia o que isso era na altura.
Uma luta que não imaginam,
foi um inferno naquele escritório
durante um ano ou dois,
a tentar recuperar, mas recuperámos.
E partimos para o Grease,
partimos para o Miss Saigão,
trazemos o Cats,
e no Cats batemos todos os recordes
que já alguma vez aconteceram
no Coliseu de Lisboa
e no Coliseu do Porto.
Qualquer coisa como 200 000 espetadores.
Para quem não anda nesta área,
200 000 espectadores,
nem mesmo o La Féria quando escreve
que mais de um milhão de pessoas viram,
consegue bater.
Nem mesmo quando ele escreve.
É impossível, não há
pessoas para verem estas coisas.
E nós fomos fazendo.
Vem aí o Mamma Mia,
já devem ter visto, vamos voltar a fazer.
No entretanto,
como estávamos muito sossegados,
começámos a descobrir
o que é que os estrangeiros queriam.
Então levámos o fado para o estrangeiro.
Não somos nós que o fazemos sozinhos,
felizmente hoje há dezenas
de empresas a trabalhar nesta área
e há dezenas de empresas a levar
o que é português para o estrangeiro.
Agora na cultura, acreditem
que, se fazer cá já é difícil,
fazer no estrangeiro é mais difícil.
Não é.
O que é que eu consigo fazer?
A Cátia Guerreiro
— só para vocês terem uma ideia —
nestes últimos 30 dias,
fez 17 concertos no estrangeiro.
Porquê?
Porque o fado está na moda,
porque é bom, porque é bonito,
porque é nosso
e porque são
coisas fantásticas que nós fazemos
também em termos
culturais para o estrangeiro.
Hoje, representamos um artista brasileiro,
representamos a Dulce Pontes
que está permanentemente no estrangeiro,
por isso é que nós
não a vemos em Portugal, é muito raro.
Trabalhamos com
os Improváveis e o Carlos Moura
e ainda temos uma orquestra
que tem uma base num teatro em Lisboa.
Fazemos agenciamento
de tudo isto, criamos pacotes
e ainda temos alguns grupos estrangeiros
que não estão aqui.
Representamos um grupo
argentino chamado Tango Pasión,
com quem fazemos
espetáculos no mundo inteiro
e um outro francês,
com os campeões do mundo de sapateado
mas com gestão portuguesa,
que são os Tap Factory.
Estão neste momento na China, durante
10 semanas com portugueses a gerir.
Aqui vêm também
algumas das coisas dos "ses".
Há uns anos atrás, e esta talvez seja
também uma das histórias da minha vida,
estávamos no escritório e dissemos:
"Já fazemos de tudo
e não fazemos exposições."
"Mas e nós queremos fazer exposições?"
"E que exposições
é que a gente quer fazer?"
E eis que, dentro do grupo de trabalho,
há um totalmente fanático por Star Wars
— eu nem fazia a menor ideia
do que é que era, devo-vos dizer.
Comecei a estudar aquilo
e com o colega fanático desta questão:
"Eh, ninguém vai ligar nenhuma.
"Vamos começar a mandar emails para
o George Lucas e não vamos ter resposta.
"Os americanos não acreditam
muito em nós, não vai ser fácil."
Pois enganem-se,
porque nós começámos a mandar emails
e, 15 dias depois, estávamos em
São Francisco no Skywalker Ranch,
na casa do Sr. George Lucas,
a convencê-lo
que a melhor coisa que ele podia fazer
era tirar tudo o que tinha dos armazéns
e montar uma exposição
com tudo o que fez na vida dele.
Eles no princípio
acharam que nós eramos malucos
mas demorou três meses a pôr de pé.
Cinco meses depois
estávamos a fazer em Lisboa,
cinco anos depois
tínhamos corrido toda a Europa.
Com três milhões de visitantes.
A exposição voltou para os Estados Unidos.
Como sabem os que estão
mais atentos e ligados a estas coisas,
a Disney comprou a Lucasfilms e,
portanto, a exposição, neste momento,
está novamente parada,
e agora estamos no processo
de convencer os senhores da Disney,
que agora têm muitos mais
armazéns com coisas giras para tirar de lá
a ver se as conseguimos fazer.
Como a exposição voltou,
vínhamos no avião e terminámos
— O Álvaro está ali,
eu tenho dois minutos.
Tenho dez? Então pronto!
O que é que nós fizemos?
Temos que encontrar outra.
Então vamos escrever uma carta,
um emailzinho para o governo americano
e vamos tentar fazer a NASA.
A versão da Europa para a NASA.
Esta a gente não
vai conseguir, vai ser difícil.
Pois acreditem que, três meses depois,
tínhamos a exposição em Madrid,
já demos a volta
à Europa toda com ela
e só não a fazemos em Portugal
porque não há espaço para a montar.
Não acreditam, pois não?
Não há, porque os poucos espaços
que nós temos
custam mais por dia do que
qualquer espaço na Europa inteira junta.
Às vezes não há vontade
de fazer coisas, essa é que é a questão.
Recentemente, o que é que nós temos feito?
Gerimos o auditório dos Oceanos,
que está no Casino de Lisboa,
comprámos o teatro Tivoli porque o
iam mandar abaixo para fazer mais um hotel
e nós achámos que não chegava.
Os nossos "ses" têm a ver com isto.
Eu trouxe o quadro para escrever
duas coisas que
eu que é acho importante na vida
e eu pensei que ia
ter aqui muitos estudantes
e achei que fazia
algum sentido falar sobre isto.
Nós temos que acreditar.
Temos que ir
e temos que sonhar.
Os "ses" ficam mais pequeninos.
E era isto que eu vos queria dizer.